the united states is currently
experiencing a 40-year high in inflation
it's at 8.6 we haven't seen this since
the early 1980s and there's many people
trying to debate how the hell did we get
to this point now of course if you ask
the politicians they're going to
gaslight you they're going to tell you
it's every reason other than the real
one but recently jerome powell the
chairman of the federal reserve was
asked if the politicians are telling us
that russia's invasion of ukraine is
actually the cause of inflation do you
agree or not here's exactly what jerome
powell said
would you say that the word ukraine is
the primary driver of inflation in
america
no inflation was high before certainly
before the war in ukraine broke out
i'm glad to hear you say that the biden
administration seems to be intent on
deflecting blame and as recently as just
this past sunday spread the
misinformation that putin's invasion of
ukraine is the quote biggest single
driver of inflation i'm glad you agree
with me that that is not the truth now
it's great to see the chairman of the
federal reserve trying to stick to the
facts trying to look at the data he said
of course that's not the case the
inflation was already high before that
occurred now what we have to understand
is that central bankers they try to be
as independent as possible you can argue
whether they're effective or not whether
their predictions are accurate or not
and whether the actions they take
actually achieve what their stated goals
are but one thing is certain is that
many central bankers they actually try
not to be political but of course the
politicians they're gonna continue to
spin the narrative gaslight you and of
course it happens on both sides of the
aisle what you need to do is make sure
that you understand how inflation works
understand how the economy works it's a
very complex machine it's actually
almost impossible to fully understand
the nuances and the different levers but
one thing is certain the data is
overwhelming
inflation was not caused by russia's
invasion of ukraine instead inflation
was already very high it was seven
percent in december of 2021. russia
didn't invade ukraine until february and
even then you probably have a hard time
pinpointing further increases in
inflation on the actual invasion and so
ultimately the average american family
they are dealing with 8.6 inflation
right now gasoline is up 50 percent year
over year the cost of food is up 12 to
eat at home it's unsustainable for the
average family and ultimately the
federal reserve they remain committed
they want to get inflation down but the
risk they run so they can push us into a
recession maybe they can get us to a
soft landing it's a very difficult task
it would take not only a skilled central
banker to do it but also a lot of luck
and i don't think that the average
investor is going to bet on that soft
landing instead they have to decide will
we get inflation will we get a recession
or maybe we're just headed towards
stagflation and a combination of both